hello everyone and welcome back to the
clucks chest international now there
were a lot of good games played
yesterday in the chess world and we're
going to show a few of them but this one
is special and if you're wondering about
what's this whole prestigious Club well
it's actually a group of elite
grandmasters who take it upon themselves
to promote the greatest opening interest
there is which of course you know what
I'm talking about
so without further ado let's check out
this game as it's it's really a wild one
so Fabi with the white pieces opens with
E 4 we have V 5 by Wesley 92f 3 we have
Knight to c6 and Bishop to c4 as for
going for the Italian game with Bishop
to c5 and here is another position where
it is possible to go for the Evans
gambit now did Fabi go for it
yes he did he plays before and sorry
about that
the Evans gambit is on the board and the
Hubbell West will reply will he accept
the gambit or will he decline it well
this is of course one of those gambit
that is best refuted by accepting it so
Wesley goes for it Bishop characters on
b4 c3 a challenging the bishop and we
always mentioned that you could go with
say a 5 you could go to d6 d7 c5 isn't
all that impressive of white just plays
d4 and gets a very strong Center and
it's basically the same if you go back
with the Bishop to c5 it's basically the
same as if you've captured the pawn with
the night and then you go back so not
something you want to do so here Bishop
to e7 by Wesley and now just d4 so
grabbing the massive Center and now
Knight to a5 playing yet again with the
night but the white will also have to
waste a move to get rid of the bishop
now even though Knight 95 is the most
common move here then you allow black to
capture capture and go d5 and well just
to ruin your center for example captures
capture so you can go back to e3 with
the night and after let's say queen 8 5
but black is doing very well yeah so
here Fabi instead goes for Bishop to d3
he keeps the tension but now Wesley goes
d6 and again offers Fabi his pawn back
and now Fabi captures it so and we do
have to mention that Queen a4 check
doesn't win the night since after c6 the
queen
the night if some of you were thinking
about that so after d6 we have D
captures on e5 Fabi goes after his pawn
we have D captures and Knight captures
on e5 and now Knight to f6 Wesley just
makes room for the King to castle both
players Castle here castles castles and
Queen to c2 gets the Queen out of the
way prepares and makes room for the rook
to enter the game and so on
so here Bishop to d6 Wesley moves back
fabi's Knight and 5 it does go back but
with tempo as he is threatening e5 now
to win material and there is one game
where Bishop to g4 was played it was
played in 2013 in Bundesliga Alexa Shira
was able to beat Florida and honky now
we're a honky played Bishop to g4 move
but here we have Knight back to c6 and
it is already as a move 12 that we have
a completely new game so this is a one
line of the events that where black
doesn't have in at least an extra pawn
however he's not behind undeveloped
meant so black black is doing well here
so far be continued Bishop to g5 pins
the knight and h6 now we have Bishop to
h4 end now Wesley goes for g5 is well
not worried about expanding those pawns
in front of his King Bishop to g3 and
now he trades captures captures and now
even g4 preparing to go h5 later on and
maybe even h4 so Wesley takes it upon
himself to to attack white so tonight's
the h4 a good square for the knight
later on you can maybe come to five and
now Knight to e5 Wesley also finds an
excellent outpost for his Knight
you cannot go f4 as G captures on f3
alpha song will happen so you have to go
brush it back to e2 and now rook to e8
again continuing development
fob you also needs to finish developing
so Knights the d1
you could maybe develop the rook go
knife to f1 Knights that III and then
even bring this Knight over to five
which would be which would be great and
here b6 Wesley wants to develop his
Bishop to this diagonal
however rook a to d1 developing the rook
to the open D file putting it in front
of the black screen so Queen e7 and now
rook F the e1 and here while you could
continue with Bishop to b7 then you
really give white the f v square and the
Westley doesn't want to do this so
instead of going Bishop to b7 he goes
Bishop to e6 also ni square for the
bishop and you keep an eye on the f5
square but now as we mentioned Fabi goes
the Knights to f1 he wants to Riemann
over this Knight over to f5 and then
both of the Knights will be controlling
the f5 so you will always have at least
one night on f5 so rook 8 2 d 8 now
Wesley finishes development and now
Knights the e3 Fabi continues with his
plan we have Queen to c5 of course now
Wesley is expecting Knight f5 so you
don't want it to come with a double
attack on the Queen only 7 and on the
pawn and h6 so getting the Queen out of
harm's way and Knight eat the f5 now
going for the h6 pawn Wesley defends it
by first capturing and e1 and after
February captures now not going to
defend it with the King but rather just
h5 now also you keep an eye on the g4
pawn and everything is nice and you
could bring your knight over to h6 like
taking h7 bring this Knight over here
however you don't really have anything
going for you and also Wesley's the
Queen to c5 moves very tricky because
even if you go for something like this
then h4 could be very strong now Knight
cannot capture because of Queen captures
a knight and if you go for this then g3
is very strong since the Queen pins the
F do pawn
so after h5 we have looked to d4 by favi
the the rook will do a lot of good here
adding another defender to the d4 pawn
at the d4 pawn and now [ __ ] Wesley goes
back Queen to f8 and now the Queen will
do a very good job here will guard the
h6 square so the knight cannot jump and
well maybe freeze the c5 square for for
the pawn is this e5 one is a bit bit
weak for now so Queen to d2 also the
Queen on f8 prevents any rook to the
eight ideas but also now with Queen to
d2 Fabi wants to go Queen to g5 with
check so Wesley prevents it Knight to
the h7 guards to the g5 square and now
Queen upon 2 a for the pawn will no
longer be a weakness and you will
prevent the black from expanding a lot
on the Queen side so Knight back to c6
by Wesley putting pressure on fabi's
rook and here well you could play a lot
of things here you could move the rook
but Fabi goes for Knights to h6 check
first King g7 and now Knight to f5 check
checking where the King will go and here
Wesley goes for g6 he says I'm very
happy here it's a very nice square for
the King and now it's a super
complicated position a lot of things can
go wrong here a lot of things can go
well here and it's it's a question what
do you do here I'm not going to ask you
to pause the video or anything because
there are too many lines for us to cover
we're just going to show some of them so
here the question is are you worried
about Knight captures on d4 that's
basically what you want to answer you
could go Bishop to b5 to also pin the
knight as blacks rook is on e8 you could
go for night the age for check first as
now also the Queen covers the night so
you don't have to worry about that
however Fabi went for Bishop to d3 and
it's a very dangerous move however a
Queen to f4 was also very interesting as
now you offered the rook on d4 and it's
well it's it's blacks black to move
whether he goes for the rook or not if
Knight captures on d4 then you again get
a very strong Center and let's say after
f6
keeping keeping an eye on the g5 square
you have this well you have a lot of
ideas here first of all Bishop captures
on g4 doesn't work because after the
pawn captures Queen captures then you
can block with the night and after f4
the problem is black has this Queen
captures on h6 move and after of course
captures you end up being down the whole
rook so this will not be possible
however after this after this
f6 move you could go for Knights to h4
check and this is now very dangerous
however finding such disgusting engine
lines of course is not easy in a rapid
in a rapid game for example King g7 and
now the spectacular Bishop to c4 it is
in the position and now you will remove
the defender of the f5 square or if
black goes after the pawn
then you get Knight 6 to f5 with check
King to g8 and now Knight
the g6 and black is lost the queen has
really no good squares if you try Queen
f7 you just lose the Queen after Knight
to h6 check so you could move the Queen
somewhere but there aren't all that many
squares for the Queen Queen before runs
in the Queen h6 with with Queen to g7
checkmate next and it's just a terrible
position for blacks Oh Queen to f4 was
very interesting here
however Fabi goes for Bishop to d3 which
is also very interesting as well the
King is on this diagonal and the King
doesn't really have any good squares
however Wesley has a very strong
defensive move here so I feel free to
pause the video and try to find an
excellent defensive resource for Wesley
here while I give you a couple of
seconds so for those of you who were
able to do it congratulations I'm not
grabbing the rook and for those of you
who just want to enjoy the show it's
Knight to g5 nice the g5 is crucial in
defending this position as it cuts off
the Queen's defense of the night here so
now if this Knight moves you always have
King captures the knight here and that's
super important otherwise you would have
like moves like e5 threatening all sorts
of nasty discoveries and when this
Knight moves the Queen would still guard
the night so it would be very very
difficult for black so now with knife to
g5 included Wesley's position is looking
looking pretty good so here Queen to f4
by Fabi now and now f6 by Wesley ending
another defender to the knight and also
if this Knight moves you also have an
additional Square for the king so Bishop
to b5 now Fabi I says okay we now trade
rooks some nice characters on d4 Bishop
captures on the 8th with Czech Queen
captures and now a C capture Sundy for
now Fabi gets his strong center without
giving up the exchange
we have Bishop captures on f5 with
Knight captures on f5 you have to
capture with the night otherwise you
lose it so Knight captures and the Queen
captures on e4 wesley grabs a pawn and
Fabi really shouldn't trade Queens here
so he goes Knight to the h4 with check
King f7 and now Queen captures on c7
with check as we mentioned that c7 pawn
is a little bit weak so Fabi
grabs his pawn back and now Queen to e7
where's the
trait Queens and even though White has a
past upon Wesley has a two-to-one
advantage here on the Queen side and he
it will be very easy for him to create a
passed pawn of his own
so Queen the c-4 check by Fabienne again
Queen e6 Fabi declines the Queen trade
and d5 he pushes his past pawn queen 36
Wesley blocks the past pawn and now
Queen to b3 with ideas of maybe Queen to
g6 checked and then maybe you can create
some threats
so Queen to e5 not worrying about this
check and also inviting Fabi to start
pushing this passport now pushing the
pass pawn is super dangerous because if
d6 d7 checked in here it will be very
hard for you to do anything more what it
will be very easy for black to just pick
up that point and if Knight g6 you could
very easily run in tonight Queen to e1
check King to h2 and now a tricky move
like Knight to f3 check which is super
complicated but it will win the game for
black for example G captures Queen
captures with trick
you're gonna go king h1 and now G
captures threatening checkmate Knight
has the block as now the G 2 square is
covered but now Queen e1 check King 2 h2
and f2 threatening to bring another
Queen into the game so Knight to f3
attacking blacks Queen but now you play
f1 and bring the knight into the game
with check King do you want and now it's
a queen e3 check and after all is said
and done you will also win this pawn and
you will have a 42 advantage of course
in a completely winning endgame so
allowing Fabi to push the pawn isn't all
that great for him so Fabi instead goes
Queen g6 check we have King to e7 and
now tonight's the FI with check the King
hunt begins we have King to d8 and now
King the H to first improving the safety
of his own King which is very important
and now Wesley also finds a brilliant
resource Knight to e4 and the idea is
well you want to capture here you want
to play Queen that you want and you want
to deliver checkmate with Queen to h1
check however it's still fabi's move so
Queen to g8 check with Fabi King to d7
and now Queen to f7 with check King back
to d8 and now Fabi goes for tonight the
g7 going
nice the ecigs check and hopefully you
can end the game somehow by checkmating
the black king however here Wesley finds
the very impressive age for the g3 pawn
is pinned so you cannot capture them
already there's that threat but Fabi
continues Knight the e6 check King to c8
and now comes a queen to g8 with check
so Queen to g8 check and now of course
if King D seven then this is checkmate
you cannot allow this
so King closed the b7 and here is where
the magic happens here Fabi has to go
Queen to g7 or just pick up the pawn you
should grab this pawn and continue
continue playing this because after
captures in and captures its we just
continue the game the point is that
Wesley doesn't have Queen captures on d5
if you capture on d5 then 27 wins the
game on the spot whatever you do you no
longer have the control of the c7 square
so you can't really go here and if you
try something like let's say King to a6
then just night here checks and forms
the Queen so it would be it would be of
course losing for black so after King b7
this is the way to go however far we
played King Queen to h7 with check but
now it's a bit different King to a 6 and
here Fabi grabs the h4 pawn but now now
it no longer works so feel free to pause
the video in the win this game for
Wesley while I give you a couple of
seconds so for those of you who are able
to do it congratulations on paying
attention as we already mentioned blacks
plan and for those of you who just want
to enjoy the show its Knight captures an
f2 and now you see that there's no good
way to defend against this checkmate and
the g4 point is defended so you can't
even make any room for the for the King
even if the knight moved so not much for
Fabi to do here if you try to escape why
the black just pushes you back and again
delivers checkmate so after this Queen
to h4 move we have Knight captures on f2
and now Fabi tries Queen to h8 you want
to try he wants to try and deliver some
checks here but Queen that he won by
Wesley Wesley says this will not do and
now if you go Queen to C let's say ca
checking a5 there are no
with check screen cover c3 so you cannot
continue checking the black King
so here Bobby tried Knights the c5 you
know last resort devious idea where if
the knight is captured the den Queen the
ch-check really does give you a
perpetual because after this and to
check you're gonna go this and this
check and now you cannot block with the
Queen because queen picks up the night
so you'd have to run away with the King
but now the Queen just follows King see
- you're gonna go Queen the c5 with
checking be one Queen here with check
and so on you will have a perpetual
however after Knight to the c5 check
Wesley just played King to f5 a5 and now
comes well whatever comes next doesn't
really matter because it was in this
position on move 53 that Fabiana Caruana
resigned the game and an excellent
victory for Wesley so against the Evans
gambit so here you resign because
whatever you do let's say this check or
this check doesn't really do anything
King before just escapes and after Queen
of fate let's say captures and there are
no more checks you know any any
repetition is nowhere to be found so far
be of course resigned and what what
again so even though he lost using the
Evans gambit you can see that the
positions that you know Rose over the
board were extremely complicated and had
Fabi found some similar moves other than
that
Bishop to d3 line where Wesley found the
incredibly resourceful resourceful
Knight to g5 it could have gone either
way so yeah you as you can see even
though these are two elite players it's
not the the problem is not within the
Evans gambit it's just you know it's
just that it happens and it's very
important to mention that Fabi got such
incredible positions with the Evans
gambit against the player like Wesley so
who is a world Fisher random champion so
Wesley is not it's not a problem for
Wesley to play weird positions or
positions he's never seen so getting
getting excellent positions like B's
against Wesley with the Evans gambit is
incredibly impressive so even though he
lost he joins the prestigious Club and
we can only hope that others will follow
in his footsteps
strap that's the game I do hope you
enjoyed it I would like to thank Simon
Sevilla
grant
Brian carry on Gregory Roma sir and
again a yoke payment all aboard for a
contribution to my channel thank you a
lot I really appreciate it as usual you
can check - on my previous video ciarán
thank you for watching and I will see
you soon
continuing the coverage of the clutch
chest international I just realized
something happened with my board it
shifted a little bit so sure about that
I didn't realize that while I was
recording but yeah checking up on your
wonderful suggestions and of course
whatever else happens in the chess world
so thank you all I will see you soon and
have an excellent rest of your day